So the answer is, it's an error. And the
reason why is this first assignment has minutes on
the right side, but we didn't define minutes previously.
So, if we use a variable that's not defined, there's
no meaningful value for this. The Python interpreter will
give us an error. Let's see that in the
Python interpreter. So here, we have just the first
assignment. When we run this, we get the error that
says the name minutes is not defined. Minutes is not defined
because we didn't introduce that variable yet. It looks like we're defining
it. We've gotten in on the left side, but the right
side needs to execute first. So without knowing the value of minutes,
there is no sensible value this code can produce, so running
the code produces an error. If we have a statement before this
that gives minutes a value, then the code will be fine.
We can run this, there's no error. And we can do the
assignment that we had in the quiz, assigning to seconds
minutes times 60, and print the value of seconds. This
works now, but only because we added this definition. We
need to always introduce a variable before we use it.